طلب الامين العام للامم المتحده
المجتمع الدوليه بالتعامل بجديه مع
تحذيرات العلماء من التهديد المحتمل
للذكاء الاصطناعي الذي يقولون انه لا يقل
خطوره عن الحروب النوويه من جانبها اكدت
نقلا عن مسؤولين امريكيين سايا واشنطن
لاحتواء دور الصين في وضع سياسات استخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي في العالم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كندا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما الحيثيات التي يستند
اليها المحذرون من التهديد الوجودي الذي
يمثله الذكاء الاصطناعي على مستقبل
البشريه وما مدى وجاهت هذا التهديد وما
الذي دفع واشنطن الى محاوله احتواء تاثير
بيجين في مجال السياسات الذكاء الاصطناعي
وعلى اي نحو سترد الصين على التحرك
الامريكي في هذا الصدد وما الدور الذي
يمكن ان يلعبه الذكاء الاصطناعي في مستقبل
الصراع بين القوى الكبرى وما سبل تجنيد
البشريه مخاطره التي تعالت التحذيرات منها
[موسيقى]
اقل من اسبوعين بعد بيان تحذيري وقع عليه
بشكل جماعي قاده عدد من كبريات شركات
التكنولوجيا وخبراء الذكاء الاصطناعي في
العالم نبه البيان الى خطوره هذه التقنيه
واحتمال ان تؤدي الى خطر انقراض البشريه
ودعا الى ضروره سرعه تقنينها والسيطره
عليها وطالب الامين العام للامم المتحده
باخذ هذه التحذيرات على محمل الجد مشيرا
الى تشبيه هؤلاء العلماء مخاطر الذكاء
الاصطناعي بالحرب النوويه
اعلن ايضا انه سيشكل مجلسا استشاريا علميا
يسانده خبراء من جهات عده منها اليونسكو
للنظر بسرعه في قضيه الذكاء الاصطناعي
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن
من ثمارا الضابطه السابقه في وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه سي اي اي
ومن نيويورك ينضم الينا
انزيموك كبير الباحثين في مركز الصين
والعولمه ومقره العاصمه الصينيه بجينه
والموجود حاليا في نيويورك كما ينضم الينا
او نبدا في الفقره الاولى من هذا البرنامج
النقاش مع
ضيفنا الدكتور وائل
وائل عبد المجيد نرحب اذا بضيوفنا
وبالدكتور وائل عبد المجيد استاذ الذكاء
الاصطناعي ومؤسس مختبر الذكاء البصري
وتحليل الوسائط المتعدده بجامعه جنوب
كاليفورنيا اهلا بكم جميعا هذا معك دكتور
وائل عبد المجيد في تحليل هذه الدائره
الظاهره بما انك مختص خبير مختص في موضوع
الذكاء الاصطناعي هل كل ما نسمعه من
تحذيرات من مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي
وصل الى حد تشبيهه بالحرب النوويه هل هذا
واقعي ام ان بالفعل الامر خطير الى هذه
الدرجه
اشكركم على الاستضافه الحقيقه ان هو
الكلام
اول كلام عائل اسمعه في الموضوع بعيدا عن
المبالغات
المريئه بتضارب المصالح والتوجيه المضلل
من شركات زي جوجل
[موسيقى]
اللي بيتكلم تحديدا على الاشاعات
والمعلومات المضلله وزياده الكراهيه
والتمييز هي دي المخاطر الانيه للذكاء
الصناعي بعيدا عن الكلام الكبير بتاع
الاكزيستنشن
المخاوف اللي ممكن تحصل بعد 100 سنه
هو دي المخاطر الانيه للذكاء الصناعي
بمساله الاشاعات واللي لها خطر مباشر على
الديمقراطيات مساله التحيه والتمييز في
المجتمعات
نعم يعني فعلا
انت ترى انها مخاطر واقعيه كما وصفها
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيرش لكن ما امكانيه احتواء هذه المخاطر
الحقيقه امكانيه احتواء المخاطر لازم تحصل
عن طريق عده اتجاهات مختلفه من الناحيه
العلميه
العلماء المختصين
بمحاربه التمييز ومحاربه الاشاعات من
المنتجه من خلال انظمه الذكاء الصناعي
محتاجين يكملوا شغل في هذا الاتجاه
الحكومات والسياسيين على سواء على المستوى
الدولي او المستوى
الدول المنفصله محتاجين يعملوا قوانين
تحدد من
انتشار المعلومات المضاليه وزياده
الكراهيه والتمييز لان زي ما حضرتك تعرفي
كل انظمه الذكاء الصناعي بيتعمل لها او
تدريب على كميه معلومات كتير جدا من
الانترنت والمعلومات دي ما بيحصلهاش اي
نوع من انواع التلقيح وبالتالي هتعكس كل
كل الكراهيه والتمييز الموجود في التاريخ
البشري وفي نفس الوقت اجهزه الذكاء او
منظومات الذكاء الصناعي دي عندها قدره على
اشاعات وتعليق تخليق معلومات مضلله سواء
على المستوى البصري او المستوى اللغوي سهل
جدا على الناس ان هم يصدقوها فالحقيقه
الحاجات دي فعلا حقيقيه ومحتاجه شغل في
عده اتجاهات الاتجاه الاخر الحقيقه المهمه
جدا الشغل فيه مساله انتشار المعلومات
المضلله والمميزه
بتزود الكراهيه على السوشيال نتورك زي
تويتر وفيسبوك وانستجرام وتيك توك
او المنصات اللي زي بتاعه السوشيال محتاجه
يتعمل لها تقنين من خلال الحكومات ومن
خلال المجتمع الدولي
قبل ان ننتقل الى ضيفينا ننوه الى الخبر
العاجل الذي يشاهده الان بالصوت والصوره
وهو موكب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامبو وهو في
طريقه الى المسؤول امام المحكمه
الفيدراليه في ميامي لمواجهه اجراءات
مقاضاته في قضيه تتضمن 37 تهمه يواجهها
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالدو والتي قد
تقف عائقا امام ترشحه لانتخابات الرئاسه
الامريكيه طبعا هذه الصور مباشره وتاتينا
مباشره من مكان توجه موكب الرئيس الامريكي
دونالد ترامب الى مقر المكان المحاكمه مقر
المحكمه فيما يعني
اعود اليك دكتور وائل عبد المجيد وقد شرحت
لنا بالتفصيل مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي لكن
قطبه الذكاء الاصطناعي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والصين وايهما اقوى برايك في
هذا المجال
اعتقد لحد الان الولايات المتحده بالتاكيد
اقوى على المستوى على المستوى الجامعات
وعلى مستوى الشركات زي جوجل وزي open اي
كل الناس دلوقتي بتسمع عن
الانظمه دي مصموله المتحده في بس في نفس
الوقت الصين على مستوى الجامعات وعلى
المستوى الحكومه اقوياء جدا في الذكاء
الصناعي الميزه الاساسيه اللي بتدي
الولايات المتحده
زي ما بيقولوا او
المميزه الاساسيه الولايات المتحده هي ان
شركه
انفيديا المصنع الاساسي
للشبس بتاعه الاي اي هي شركه امريكيه وما
فيش مثيل لها في الصين وبالتالي حصول
الصين على الاجهزه اللي تقدر بها تعمل
منظومات ذكاء صناعي ضخمه زي تشيلسي لسه
لحد الان محدود بس بالرغم من ذلك من السوق
من السهل على الصين انها تعمل نفس
الاجهزه اللي بيتعمل بيتعمل عليها
الصناعي لان العلوم متقدمه جدا في الصين
في الوقت الحالي شكرا لك يا دكتور وائل
عبد المجيد ونذهب الى ضيفينا في نيويورك
واشنطن
يعني واضح ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
متخوفه قلقه من موضوع استخراج منظمه
اليونسكو استفراد الصين بمنظمه اليونسكو
في تحديد معايير وسياسات تتعلق بالذكاء
الاصطناعي ما الذي تخشاه بالضبط امريكا في
هذا الامر
اعتقد انها ما تخشاه الولايات المتحده على
وجه الخصوص ولا سيما في مجتمع الاستخبارات
الامريكيه هو ان الصين تقوم بسد ثغره او
ملء فجوه وتركتها الولايات المتحده حين
توقفت الولايات المتحده عن تمويل منظمات
اليونسكو ثم انسحبت منها يسر الصين ان
تتقدم وتملا هذه الفجوه وتصير من ابرز
صانع السياسات وواضعي القواعد في اليونسكو
ومع التهديد الناشئ بوجود الذكاء
الاصطناعي ليس فقط التهديدات التي سوف
تستخدم من قبل دول مارقه او عدائيه او
خصوم بطريقه سيئه ولكن ايضا ان تخرج تقنيه
الذكاء الاصطناعي عن السيطره تماما هذا
اكثر ما يقلق الحكومه الامريكيه ولا سيما
الاستخبارات الامريكيه وما نشهده هنا هو
ان الولايات المتحده تحاول ان تلحق
بالركاب حيث انها
قامت بابتكارات فيبرانيه مثلا انا كنت
صغيره ولم نتخيل يوما ان نرى هذا التطور
في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي يصل الى مرحله
الحرب او احتمال الحرب وهذا اكثر ما يقلق
الولايات المتحده هذا ما يقلق الولد
المتحده الامريكيه انديمو كيف
تتابع الصين هذا القلق الامريكي
اعتقد ان الصين او حكومته هذه يدركون بشكل
واضح مدى اهميه الذكاء الاصطناعي وان هذا
يعتبر يعتبر
التكنولوجيا للاغراض العامه مثل الكهرباء
والتي تؤثر على كل طبقات المجتمع
والتعليم التجاره العسكريه وما الى ذلك
اعتقد ان الصين تدرك ايضا
بانها تشكل
فرصه لا سابقه لها كبيره جدا كما خطرا
كبيرا وان الصين لطالما كانت مفتوحه امام
التعاون مع اي بلد بصرف النظر عن
الايدرجيه او القيم
وهذا بالنسبه لهم اهم شيء هو بناء مستقبل
مشترك دون حاجه الى فرض قيم مشتركه هذا
ايضا ينطبق على الذكاء الاصطناعي واعتقد
ان الصين تثبت بانها ملتزمه بالتعاون مع
اي بلد على اساس الاحترام المتبادل
واحترام السياده
حين
الصين كما يقول انديمارك ظلت دائما منفتحه
على التعاون في هذا المجال وفي مجالات
اخرى كما قال الا تتحمل واشنطن مسؤوليه
الخطا الذي ارتكبه الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب بالانسحاب من منظمات مهمه من منظمه
اليونسكو في هذا المجال وايضا من موضوع
البيئه وغيرها وكيف يمكنها تدارك هذا
الخطا
في الحقيقه صححنا هذا الخطا من خلال
انتخاب ضد ترامب واخرجناه من منصبه ولكن
اجابه على السؤال الولايات المتحده
باعتمادها منصه انعزاليه كما فعلت اداره
ترامب لم تخدم مصلحتها ولا مصلحه العالم
يجب ان نكون مشاركين في اي نقاش يحصل حول
تناغم الذكاء الاصطناعي مع حقوق الانسان
وتعزيزها وتعزيز حكم القانون والقوانين
الدوليه كيف يمكن للذكاء الاصطناعي الا
يهدد الخير العام ان وجودنا خارج هذا نقاش
امر ليس مقبولا ونحن نتحمل المسؤوليه ويجب
ان اكون جزءا من هذا النقاش انا انظر في
احتمال تشكيل وكاله دوليه
يقوموا بتنظيمي موضوع الذكاء الاصطناعي
ومشاركه الولايات المتحده وهذا اذا هذه
خطوه في المسار الصحيح طيب هذه الفكره
التي تتحدثين عنها طرحها رئيس وزراء
بريطانيا
هو صاحب فكره انشاء
منظمه دوليه على غرار مثلا المنظمه
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه منظمه يعني تهنى
بالشان الذكاء الاصطناعي هل يمكن
الانديموك هل يمكن ان يكون هذا حلا ممكنا
تتعاون بصدده الصين تضع يدها في يد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في هذا الشان
اعتقد ان هذا فعلا بالتاكيد
اسلوب مقبول جدا ولكل دوله في العالم
وخاصه بالنسبه للصين والعين المتحده ان
يشاركا في ذلك لكن علينا ان ندرك شيئا وهو
الطاقه النوويه التي
يمكن تكون مدمره
مؤثره كما يكون لديها
تاثير عن تاج الطاقه لاحظ ذلك التكنولوجيا
ضيقه في حين ان الذكاء الاصطناعي كما قلت
سابقا تؤثر على كل مجالات الحياه البشريه
وبالتالي سواء كان ذلك منطقيا ان نخلق
منظمه جديده تماما متعدده اطراف او ان
ننشئ
مجموعه من المنظمات الموجوده حاليا
لتتعاون فيما بينها ربما يكون هذا الاسلوب
الافضل لكن علينا ان تظهر لنرى لانه كما
تعلمون اليونسكو تدرس هذا الامر من جانب
اخلاقي الانسانيه
ثقافات المجتمعيه ولكن هناك
المسؤولون
الاتصالات الفنيه
معايير
الفنيه في صناعي يتجدد
مهمه وايضا واضافه لاستخدام ذلك من
كالسلاح عسكري من قبل عسكري للذكاء
الاصطناعي فالكثير من الناس يشعرون بقلق
حول التاثيرات ذلك على على
عدم التفاوت الاقتصادي ما بين الدول
مختلفه وهنا ربما منظمه مثل نظره العمل
الدوليه قد تكون هي افضل من يعمل على ذلك
اعتقد ان مساله هذه هناك
منظمه واحده متعدده الاطراف او او عدت
عناصر موجوده منظمات حاليا موجوده تتعاون
فيما بينها ربما يكون ذلك
الدراسه ذلك بالتفصيل اكبر لاحقا يعني
بالنظر الى المخاطر في بدايه البرنامج
دكتور وائل عبد المجيد شرح لنا انواع
المخاطر التي يشكلها ذكاء الاصطناعي منها
الامنيه ايضا
التجسس ربما اداره وقياده الحروب بروبوتات
وغير ذلك فضل كل هذه المخاطر هل فكره
التعاون طبعا مع الصراع الموجود بين الصين
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه هالفكره
التعاون ووضع اليد في اليد في هذا المجال
تحديدا ممكنه برايك
قابله للحياه وواقعيه هناك الكثير من
المجالات التي تفصلنا فيها اختلافات
ومنافسه او حتى عداء وتناقض في المواقف عن
دول كثيره ولكن هذا لا يمنعنا من التعاون
حول قضايا اخرى
كما اشار الضيف الكريم
فان الذكاء الاصطناعي سوف يؤثر على كل
جوانب المجتمع وعلى كل مجتمع وبالتالي
اعتقد شخصيا ان الوقت اساسي من بين
المشاكل التي شهدناها في مجال الحروب
السيبرانيه والامر صيام بالنسبه الى
الذكاء الاصطناعي هي ان هذا التكنولوجيا
قد سبقت نقاشاتنا واختلافاتنا حول
اخلاقيات استخدام التقنيات والتكنولوجيا
وهذا حصل اكثر من مره عبر التاريخ
وبالتالي من المنطقي اعتبارا من الان ان
نقارب موضوع ذكاء الاصطناعي وتقنيات
الناشئه
التي تقول شريعه مطوره لها انها فيها
الكثير من المخاطر المجازفه ويجب تنظيمها
يجب ان نقارب الموضوع ونحن نفكر في
التعاون الدولي حتى مع دول مثل الصين التي
احيانا تفصلنا خلافه كثيره معها او لا نرى
من نفس المنظور معها يعني هذه النبره
التفاؤليه جميله
لكن عندما يعني نتابع ونرى نشاهد يوميا
تنامي ازمه الثقه الامريكيه في الصين
وربما ازمه تيك توك هي خير دليل على ذلك
هل هذا الكلام الذي تقولينه قابل للتطبيق
برايك واقعي ترينه
انا اتي من خلفيه استخباريه ونحن نعتمد
شعار شعار مفاده ابقي اعدائك اقرب من
اصدقائك حتى لا اريد ان ابدو هذا او اننا
نتحدث عن خلقي بيئه فيها تعاون مفاجئ مع
الصين لا لن يحصل ذلك بطريقه مفاجئه نحن
حذرون تجاه التهديدات
والمجازفات الامنيه السيبرانيه تجاه الصين
ولكن انا لا ارى افضليه افضليه في مقاربه
موضوع
مهم بالنسبه الى الانسانيه لا ارى
الافضليه في مقاربتي هي من منظور الحذر
يجب ان نعمل على تعزيز التعاون مع الصين
ومع دول مختلفه اذا قربنا موضوع الذكاء
الاصطناعي باعتباره تكنولوجيا الرائعه
وممتازه ولكن طبعا
لديها قدره على الاضرار بالانسانيه جمعاء
بالبشريه جمعاء وليس كدوله واحده هذا هو
التفكير الصحيح طيب انت يعني ما الذي يمكن
ان تقدمه الصين في هذا الصدد وهي عليها
ملاحظات كثيره في المساله الاخلاقيه او
البعد الاخلاقي في الذكاء الاصطناعي
اعتقد ان هذه واحد من اهم الاسئله عمقا
فيما يتعلق بالذكاء الاصطناعي بمعنى ان
الكثير من العلماء والمهندسين يعملون على
الذكاء الاصطناعي يقولون انه قد لا يكون
الامر بعيدا جدا في المستقبل قبل ان تبدا
الذكاء الصناعي بالتاثير
بحيث يقصحني قدرات بشريه مثل الوعي بالذات
والصفات الاخرى التي لحد الان كنا نعتبرها
محصوره فقط للبشر وايضا هناك قلق بين
الذكاء الصناعي قد يصبح اكثر ذكاء من
البشر وهذا قد يشكل خطرا على البشريه
بكاملها وبالتالي فان هذه الاسئله
المتعلقه بالاخلاقيات تصبح مهمه جدا
وبالتالي بالتاكيد ان منهجيه الصين حسب
رايي اكثر شموليه واكثر انتظاما
فيما يتعلق
بمقاربه الذهنيه والفكريه هو انها تقدم
ايضا قدرات حكوميه فريده من نوعها لتطبيق
وتنفيذ السياسات بشكل فعال
عمونيا من الطبقات من المستوى
الوطني الى المدينه او ثم الى حتى الاحياء
وذلك ايضا عبر كل الطبقات المجتمع ونعلم
ان الولايات المتحده
يقولون احيانا انها قد لست غير قادره
مننويا ان تقوم بوضعيه السياسات
المستقبليه
الرئاسه لاربع سنوات نعم ادركنا وقت
البرنامج وربما من اللافت ان
يعني نركز على الجمله التي قلتها وهي ان
الذكاء الاصطناعي تفوق او قد يتفوق على
الذكاء البشري او يقتل الذكاء البشري بهذا
ناتي الى ختام هذه الحلقه واشكر في ختامها
من نيويورك اندي نوك الباحث في مركز الصين
والعولمه ومقره العاصمه الصينيه بجينه
والموجود حاليا في نيويورك شكرا له وايضا
شكرا
الضابطه السابقه في وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه في واشنط
والى هنا ناتي الى ختام هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]